hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to uh 2023 today is January
1st uh 2023 the first day of the new
year
so you know just a really brief you know
if you like the videos that we put out
you know be sure to like the channel and
subscribe to it as well as you know like
the videos give them a thumbs up you
know it helps us in that YouTube
algorithm so you know as we advance into
2023 you know Traders are looking for
more innovative ways to analyze and
understand order flow so to accomplish
this goal you know we've developed New
Order flow analysis techniques that
we've put into our order flow footprint
software you know I've seen recently
other software companies have been
adapting them so you know I want to do a
video to sort of talk about you know
some of the newer ways that people
Traders are looking at order flow
because you know early adopters of these
new techniques are going to have an edge
when it comes to their ability to
identify uh successful trading
opportunities so it's essential for any
good Trader in 2023 not only to sort of
embrace the order flow but also have a
good understanding of the underlying
Concepts and more importantly how to
apply them in order flow you know like I
said I see a lot of software vendors out
there
copying you know some of the forms of
analysis that we're doing and that's
fine you know people say oh don't you
have a problem with that well not really
because you know it's more mainstream
and when people know how to use it that
just benefits us you know the order flow
Community more because it helps take the
um knowledge a step further and begin
you know if you have a way of analyzing
the market but no one else is doing it
what's going to help move that market
right because if I buy something or if I
buy five lots of s PS but nobody else is
buying it the Market's not going to go
up but you know when more people
understand the order flow and see an
inflection point in the market based off
of you know Delta or value or whatever
and they're also getting long off of
that that same idea you know that helps
us overall right it's it's not like
we're just trading in a vacuum against
everybody else in the world you know we
need to so I don't say trade together
but you know we need other people to
also understand and you know trade in
the same direction as us to help us you
know become more successful help the
trades work out because again you know
what people don't realize is as soon as
you get into a trade there's nothing
else you could do about that trade
what you need for the trade to work out
is say you're buying right you need more
people to start coming in and buying
right buy aggressively to make the price
go higher but if nobody else is buying
Market's not going to go up so you know
as as more and more of our forms of
analysis become mainstream it honestly
just benefits everybody
when we know what to look for so this is
crude oil this is on uh Friday
December 30th right the last trading day
and
yeah
you know crude oil
you know we're getting back up above the
eighty dollar uh price level and
I don't know what uh this 2023 is going
to bring but you know at this time this
is around nine in the morning just after
nine in the morning and we're sort of
just going you know sideways right you
can see here we had made this new high
79.50 just just before nine o'clock and
we came off
after that you know traded on towards
you know the double O area Double O's
down here we get a one but then we're
just sort of trading you know a little
bit back and forth within the market uh
started a little rally and then dropped
uh quite nicely here from you know
basically the 7930 area back you know
below to 78 73 which is the opening
price that's this yellow line here and
again you know coming up into this this
area here it just really a lot of
back and forth action right not really
anything trending if anything it looked
like maybe it's going to start to rally
and go back up that high at 79.50 but by
looking at the order flow now the Deltas
are honestly not giving you much at this
point you know you're getting some
um strong negative Deltas right minus 60
minus 38 you know but then you see a 40
a positive one you know and everything
else is kind of small you know 6 10
negative five zero four
um you know 11.
and then it starts coming up in here and
it starts dropping off right this right
as this Market is falling over and what
can you look for in the order flow that
is telling you you know what we're not
going to come back up to this high at
79.50 that we're going to start to
reject it and potentially sell off
um you know your first your target
should be this uh 78.73 and you know
more importantly right we had that high
up here
came off sort of making that run back up
you know I'm always watching when a
market is sort of coming back up to a
high of the day or the low of the day
and in this case you know we start
working our way back up towards this
High we get all the way up to
79.40 and then the selling comes in
okay but at this High bar here what's
the delta
it's minus one
what does that tell you well again you
know sometimes these Deltas you know
they come on zero minus one positive one
you had a positive one here
um you know here you got minus one and
this is a Time based chart sometimes
it's a little bit more coincidental when
it lands on zero or or minus one because
it's a time-based chart and the chart
has to close but again it's closing
around basically
unchanged in the Delta here you had a
zero here you got a one here you got a
minus one
and how I would read that is okay well
trading is kind of equally distributed
right I don't want to say it's oh it's
negative one you got a lot of sellers no
you got one right minus one rather
in the delta okay how's the volume
volume is about average for what you're
looking at you know 167 it's a little
bit uh on the heavier side I mean you
got 190 but it's a 134 or 98 119
um you know 159 147 so it's around
average of what you're looking at here
over the last uh you know to what's on
this chart at least I don't see you have
to go back and look at the last 100 bars
or anything you know really volume is
relative to what's just been trading
okay so again it's it's minus one
that's really nothing to go off of right
say well it's negative you know that
means something okay fine you know the
next bar minus 11 and then positive 23
and then minus 57. so it doesn't really
get strong negative till you get to this
minus 57 area but you got green red red
what do you have you have pointed
controls migrating lower right you got
your high bar here with the point of
control
right you know it's sort of in the
middle of the bar but then obviously the
red candle lower point of control
another bar red candle lower point of
control another bar red candle lower
point of control what is interesting on
this little group of pointed controls is
each point of control is coming in at a
level lower than the low of the previous
bar
right so this one here is coming at 29
the low of this previous bar is 11 sorry
31.
then the low of this candle is 25 point
of control is coming in at 24. low of
this bar is 21 point of control is
coming in at 20. so you've got
these three point controls that are
migrating lower and they're coming in at
lower levels than the low of the
previous bar which is bearish right but
again you know you you want to be
looking at you know signs in the order
flow so I know volume is migrating lower
okay but
what you also want to understand right
when you're looking at point of controls
right point of control is the price
level in the bar where the most volume
traded you know that is you know giving
you a clue obviously you got these
buying imbalances in there right the 20
the 10 the 22.
which is actually I'll say Weighing on
the Delta because when you have these
buying imbalances in the red candles
essentially it's telling you supply
again you know it's 20 contracts right
it's not 200 but again it's giving you
an imbalance the five against 20 but
that's kind of a supply that you know
there's a bit more volume coming in on
the offer and that's absorbing whatever
buying is taking place there again I'm
not saying oh this this 10 lots of
Supply coming tomorrow is like 10
contracts right it's two against 10
which is giving that imbalance but
you know that's something to just sort
of keep an eye on uh when you're
watching the order flow sort of looking
for these imbalance with bar direction
divergences if if you will
because you know if there wasn't that
aggressive bind if this was just like a
normal
um bar here or say nasty normal bar but
if this 20 was just say five contracts
okay now of course that would change the
whole Dynamics you wouldn't have that
aggressive buying but
instead of you know a minus 15 Delta
you'd probably be looking at you know a
minus 30 Delta but you know it is what
it is and it's coming in at just minus
11. but really talking about the new
advances
this is something that we've introduced
over a year ago and then I'm starting to
see it in more and more uh software is
looking at the value area for a bar so
it's one thing to look at the point of
controls which you know gives you a very
quick look at where the volume is in the
bar but when you look at the value area
of a bar
you're defining you know where 70 of the
volume is traded in the bar and what's
happening basically so
we get up here to this high
okay and then you start seeing obviously
the value area here that's this red
bigger box
the red bigger box the red bigger box
and what do you have right you're
starting to gap down right from this
value area to this value area right then
they sort of overlap here and then you
have another Gap in the value area from
here to here here to here and that's
what you start to see when a market is
really starting to move right you're
seeing value move lower so if I'm
looking for a market that's breaking
down I'm going to be looking obviously
for Value moving lower and gaps in the
value area now people are going to say
well here you got Gap here on the move
to the upside
the problem with this move is this bar
here right if this bar was higher and
you're having a gap between this bar and
this bar to the upside I'd be looking at
it you know sort of in the opposite way
I'm looking at this but nevertheless you
know it gapped up right which I like to
see but then a gap down which is not
what I like to see
um and then it got back up which I like
to see but then you know again it sort
of puts in this nice little
um move up higher and then starts coming
down Gap Gap Gap Gap
okay but by the time you get from this
Gap to this Gap even down in here you
shouldn't be waiting for another gap
down here
you should be already starting to pick
it up off of this Gap and off of this
Gap not even waiting for this bar here
to finish
with The Gap so at least you could catch
something from you know around the 7900
to 05 area to catch that move back down
into the mid 70s you know a quick 25
cent move you know people say well is
this a small move it's 25 cents
right which is you know in crude it's 10
cents a tick ten dollars a tick you know
that's a quick 250 move down and you
know your stop is
Behind These gaps here right the sort of
the whole Gap Theory applies when you're
looking at these gaps in the value area
right now sort of another trick that I
like to use is
when you're looking at the value areas
just really quick is when you draw them
out okay
they can draw them out fixed or until
tested so fixed would be you know just
either in this bar over set number of
bars but until tested means that it's
going to draw out the value area until
the market retests that value area
and when I start seeing it like
consecutively right here's one another
one another one
that's sort of this cascading effect all
right that's just just gives me a nice
visual of a market starting to move down
you know just as you're starting to get
it to move up here again
I got one I got two green ones here I'd
be looking ideally for a third one
coming up in here but none we see it
shift so even though this looked a
little bit bullish coming up in here in
terms of these uh value areas that we're
not trading back into
it starts turning and I got the bearish
one I got the bearish one you know I got
one I got two you know these two are
overlapping
um buy this one again the third one you
know somewhere in here again ideal place
to get short around you know 0.506 again
because you got one here one here maybe
you're waiting for this bar to finish or
even you know maybe you're getting a
little excited because again you'd be
getting short somewhere around in here
between 05 all the way up to 15 hiding
behind this value area and this value
area for a move initially right down to
this opening price which is where it
traded down into right and again how I
like to use these value areas
there the red ones are going to be my
resistance the green ones are potential
support right so
while we're selling off right I got
another
value area here acting as resistance
Market sold off traded back into that
value area and then started selling off
again again not much of a sell-off at
this point from you know 84 85 down to
you know the mid 70s
but you know if you want to just throw
an offer in here or a bid in here you
could have a very tight stop just on the
other end of that value area
to catch you know a nice move you're
risking you know say you're getting long
or start getting short here at 84 you
just have a stop you know you can call
it five ticks at 89.
you know even if you just got to take
profit at 69 which would give you
takes profit versus a four tick stop
you know that's worth it right there
just as you know if you're trying to buy
it here
okay yeah you put in a buy limit here at
79.20 you know 22 and you just have a
stop down here at you know 19. just on
the other side okay you get stopped out
but you could have nice trades like this
one you're risking four to get back 15.
so
you know that's how I like to use value
areas
um you know it gives me a more visual
look at what's happening in the order
flow as opposed to just looking at the
point of controls and the Deltas I mean
I'm still looking at the point of
controls in Deltas but just gives me you
know a new insight into
where what's happening in terms of value
because if you've ever you know done
analysis
with value right you know that markets
are always looking for Value when it
finds value it will balance but when
imbalances happen is when the market is
looking for new value okay so you know
that would be the end of this video I'll
catch you guys on the next video don't
forget to hit the like button
And subscribe to the channel thanks
everyone bye-bye